[Music]
it's very unseasonable
why why would a fan do that
oh that's unfortunate
but you handled it with Grace Harry you
have to kind of think about what's
what's more important yep you saw that
right Harry Styles reacts to getting hit
with a water bottle in that area while
on stage at a show in Chicago
on Saturday during the end of his love
on tour pit stop in the windy city Harry
was in the middle of his performance
chopping it up with fans per usual
[Applause]
and out of nowhere somebody in the crowd
catches Harry off guard by launching a
water bottle directly at the singer's
crotch
[Music]
it's very unseasonable
[Applause]
oh that's unfortunate
Harry rises above the unfortunate Moment
by literally shaking it off and making
light of the situation
seems like Harry is taking a page out of
his ex-girlfriend Taylor Swift's book
the 28 year old didn't ask security to
seek out the person who threw the bottle
anyway instead he quickly put the focus
back on his loving fans many of those
fans traveled across the world to see
him
[Applause]
Denmark everybody
famously a very happy country
are you happy son look at him
well speaking of Happiness Harry has a
lot to smile about right now I've
already done the the work part so this
is definitely the fun bit he has a Hit
album out Harry's house
[Music]
a sold out tour and the box office
success of his movie don't worry darling
not everyone gets this opportunity
directed by Olivia Wilde whom he's also
dating what dating advice would you give
I guess just keep doing what you're
doing Harry because based on these
pictures of the two packing on the PDA
in New York City a few weeks ago they
are still going strong despite rumors
they split people can interpret a lot of
different things in uh in different ways
fans started speculating that the couple
called it quits after Harry and Olivia
were distant from one another during the
Venice Film Festival it's also rumored
that Harry Spit on His co-star Chris
Pine at the film's premiere something
Chris's rep denies and it's something
that his girlfriend Olivia shut down
during an appearance on The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert did Harry Styles
spit on Chris Pine why or why not
support your answer she did not but I
think it's a perfect example of like
people will look for drama anywhere they
can Harry did not spit on Chris in fact
but that time will tell no right he
really didn't
[Music]